the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or to view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
so today we are going to spend a little
bit of time discussing the bimbo reading
which introduces a really important
concept for us that is the concept of
technological determinism I think this
is particularly important in our look at
music and technology because music
technologies I think raised really
interesting questions and pose really
interesting examples and counter
examples of this question of
technological determinism so we'll spend
a little time talking about that then
we're going to experiment with some
electromagnetic properties of sound
generation so we're going to generate a
mini telharmonium light as collins likes
to say using a simple motor we're going
to experiment with a humbucker pickup
and see what kind of sounds we can pick
up with that and then we're going to
build a little oscillator using the
Schmitt trigger model that Colin's
nicely provides for us good questions in
general keep in mind we will have
another quiz next Thursday a week from
today that's right yeah so keep that in
mind okay good so let's start with the
bimber article and I believe Julian you
are responsible for this one okay
technical term ism which the time
describes as the user relationships
between technology and human activity or
the significance of Technology this
social change but he kind of talks about
job there's a huge debate on what the
concept actually means right so you guys
are going others sort of three types of
technological determinism the norm basic
has logical secret accounts and an
engine unintended consequence accounts
so okay just proud to those and goes
two different
okay good and the big picture his goal
his big question for this article is
what basically like how technology
relates to social aspects or does it
really ok so how technology relates to
culture and society what action what
power technology has in relation to
society and culture and specifically
this article on the biggest picture he's
asking a question that doesn't really
concern us but what's the big question
he's trying to answer with this article
did what Marcus city was it really
technical big loss was marks a
technological determinist that's sort of
the big question but that's the least
interesting for us people debate that a
lot and that's an interesting issue but
that's not really relevant for us all
right this article for us provides us
with a really nice way of just getting
an introduction to some of the different
approaches to what technological
determinism is so let's first discuss a
little bit about what is technological
determinism without looking at his three
cases let's just talk about this in
general what is this idea of
technological determinism just in
general try from the highest most
broadest description first so you have
this aspect of this technology affect us
and how did that case how much does it
affect us say that there's also the
deterministic / words like bo is what's
going to happen in technological a
deterministic since only that's at times
do we affect it right we actually have
control over them technology right I
think it the biggest in the biggest
sense that's the question we're trying
to answer here is technology an
independent force that acts on its own
or do we have some control I think in
the biggest sense that's the question
this gets to what is this concept of
determinism in general determinism
yeah it basically gets to the question
of free will determine is about why
would how wise determinism I mean how
could we not have free will well what
are you talking about I make choices
yeah decide that possibly the course of
human history or any event that happens
well predetermined by the choices that
made us so our decision whether or not
your free will it's actually a decision
or that's just a conclusion which one of
their decision as me right but in that
case then you still have decisions
playing a part that might be a sort of
soft determinism a hard determinism
taking further would be what right and
why not why don't you have any choices
I think everything is just a bunch of
chemical reactions right it's just all
physics it's all physics it's all
chemical reactions it's all causal
change causality and causal change one
reaction one physical law interacts
results in another and that chain of
causal actions leads in a result that's
the idea determinism and if that is
taken to its logical extreme then we
don't have any room for free will and
that's a debate will let the
Philosopher's discuss it doesn't really
bother us well it does sometimes it
bothers me but I feel like I have free
will and you probably all do too so we
can work with that assumption just
because it's a little more practical
than the other the other major
technological determinism is not like
determinism
that does technology determine social
things like doesn't cause social things
to happen so like does the fact that the
typewriter came about a certain time to
make certain certain things happen right
cause of the typewriter or not rather
did the typewriter game ended because of
social things right right right yeah I
mean the idea that technologies on their
own just by existing play a part in the
causal chain independent of human
actions that's really at the core of the
issue okay we'll talk about that more
but let's look at members 3he categories
as three groups of approaches accounts
of technological determinism he's trying
to narrow the field because so many
people have talked about this he's
trying to narrow the field down and sort
of categorize the ideas about this let's
start with the norm based account what's
the norm based account what are the
norms that he's talking about so
basically that technology is living
we will create technology they get
together to make things their actions
are covered whatever political body is
grueling and also he talked about kind
of like the favor productivity over like
advil things right right that's the key
that I think that's the key point in
norm based accounts somebody else want
to build on that idea norm based so the
norms he's talking about he's basically
talking about where people give up some
control to technology right giving up
some control to technology and he's
talking about that base on these norms
and what are the norms you mentioned one
of the norms that he mentions which was
uh which one did you say productivity
productivity that's right what are some
of the other norms that he describes
logic logic and Lofton with logic is
reason logic reason productivity
efficiency those are the norms that he's
talking about in the norm spaced account
and what he's talking about how this is
a sort of technological determinism is
that people say well I don't know if I
like this technology but it makes my
life easier it's more efficient or it's
a reasonable approach that's sort of a
giving up of some control but not all
control ultimately does he say that the
norm based account is a technological
determinism no he rejects it because
humans still play some role but don't
have but don't have complete control
okay the second one let's go to let's
jump to unintended consequences what are
the unintended consequences
creating it for some purpose and then
lay down the road it has some completely
different thing good good now how was
that a technological suggest perhaps a
technological determinism honey for
instance like he brought the example of
cars they were created to like clean up
the streets so there would be horses
everywhere whatever right and then it
you know kind of love do this little co2
emissions all right that's not my
technological determinism because you
know we could have prevented that
because we could have predicted it
personally yeah unintended consequences
technologies have results that we may
not foresee and that gives us a sign
that the technology it suggests perhaps
the technology has some sort of agency
that technology is doing something out
of our control that's another reason why
I might be seen as a technological terms
as bimber ultimately say that it's a
technological determinism no he cuts
that went out to and why makes a
distinction that because it's just
because it's uncontrollable and like
unintended doesn't mean this
deterministic right that's true and also
that humans still have agency rights
human still played a role in in creating
those technologies introducing them so
it doesn't completely remove the human
agency finally we get to the logical
sequence account which is the one that
he wants to hold up as the real pure
technological determinism and what is
the logical sequence account
technology creates social change that's
one aspect of the logical sequence
account what are some other aspects of
the logical sequence account yeah the
existing technology is always entirely
determined what the next right and that
there's a logical sequence both its
logical one leads to another and that
there's a sequence anybody want to flush
out that idea a little bit more I mean
what is logical sequence can we think of
an example of how somebody might
interpret this logical sequence in our
world or in a some sort of practical
context yeah like you we have to go
through the steam engine before we go
through combustion engine before we move
through different technologies right we
see this all the time in simulation
games right like sim world or something
where you know you're building a little
artificial culture and you have to go
through the iron age before you do this
and that and that's an idea of a logical
sequence of technology does it have to
be like that do you agree is that it was
regardless of where that's right right
the logical sequence happens regardless
of geography regardless of background
ethnicity climates cultural context
economics politics is great I think I
may be biased because we just spread the
pitch backyard uh-huh but basically this
is making everything linear which as
we've Emma isn't really the best model
right so it does suggest a linear a
linear trajectory that's absolutely
right I think that's a good flaw what
else do that you makes you wonder about
this logical sequence it's very late
Western eurocentric is
like our sequence that we've gone
through is right and sequences that
happen somewhere yeah so the idea that
you need to go through certain steps and
like now with globalization you see like
in Africa they use cell phones but they
don't use landline phone that's a great
example like yeah it's necessarily like
frogging all these things that's true we
are we have great examples of that and
of course the idea that the logical
sequence is our sequence is is it's
pretty I think true logical because once
you look back and you see which steps
have occurred it's hard to imagine
another set of steps in current I mean I
suppose haven't had with like the
deterministic model of the universe
right because we assume that everything
if you assume determinism in the
universe and obviously technology right
but of course we have people that are
embracing technological determinism
without really being philosophical to
turnest so great so that's bhimber and
bhimber sets this out and that's the
really important thing for us now that
we have a good idea of technological
determinism he doesn't want to say these
other things our technological
determinism but I think we can think of
them as technological determinism light
they're there they happen so the reason
why I find this concepts so interesting
and relevant to us is because we find
aspects of technological determinism all
around us in our lives in commentary
that people offer both in the media and
in casual discourse and I'm wondering if
you guys can think of some casual ways
in which people reinforce or suggest
technological determinism casual ways
people talk about technology I mean just
our idea the future we've predetermined
what future is supposed to look like
uh-huh science fiction so now if someone
wants to design product that looks
futuristic good well they have a model
work with already you know it hasn't
happened interesting interesting is that
is that I think is that how is that are
people making choices there though or
are they I guess we made a choice that's
supposed to drive some type of
aesthetics of our development yeah to
the products that people develop
parceling I think that's I think there's
two layers there one is not
technological determinism that it's sort
of the result of creativity of fancy
that imagines that future that's one
part the part the technological
deterministic about that is the idea
that that future looks a certain way and
is often better or good or more
efficient or more Star Trek like the
social aesthetic is finder norm
that maybe not more during a social said
I would like I gave me like like he was
saying like a leave me have this pretty
term like way like just because of how
popular the idea of the future was like
yes maybe do the 6 p's the stereotypical
Star Trek idea right you know and then
you have like an idea about a spaceship
looks like even though it does not exist
right can you call that you can define
this as social instead can you call it
yeah that's interesting i think your
basic yeah that's interesting i think it
is a norm i think it is there's some
freedom there though right because we
can imagine other things so i think the
science fiction offers some freedom and
actually some ways out of a
technological deterministic approach let
me give you the example one way in which
i think that we see technological
determinism is whenever people give
agency to technologies so remember when
we are reading the stern article and he
kept on saying the mp3's does this the
mp3 has changed the way that we listened
to that sentence in and of itself I
think is it's problematic because it
implies that the mp3 is doing something
is the mp3 doing something do you think
it does something gets up as a nice day
forces you to listen to music at a lower
cost and a lower quality we're talking
about how to stop the mp3 but the person
who developed the mp3 encoding that does
right either the developer or the user
are real agents but this casual use of
language this attribution of agency to
technologies i think is of is a
significant point of how these
technological deterministic ideas creep
into our thinking about technology can
you think of any others yeah seriously
be said over the
these technologies embody in certain
ways the like ideas of people's like
people who made the env3 had certain
ideas about how people here and listen
and speak that's were built in the NBA
absolutely so in a sense you is a the
mp3 does do stuff it does like play in
plays like music backlink it has
properties right so like in certain
sense those processes their agency
necessarily a variety but they are
reflective of a human agency that's
right that's right but yeah and it's
like it's a sort of this casual use of
language that sort of overlooks the
humans behind the process and I think
that it's not that that's important to
recognize that that process is happening
can you think of other examples of this
sort of where we casually sort of give
technology a power that it may not
really have the nuclear bomb overturned
or
the 20th century right it's completely
different now all political science has
changed international relations and so I
mean I don't know if you get the agency
to the bottle itself or to its
adventures but right it changed a lot
that's true that's true and very
casually people say things like the
nuclear age transformed geopolitics but
again the question I raised as well was
it that or was it the people behind it
and the culture that led to that and is
it significant in our language if we
make it a distinction at the same time I
don't know if any of the people who
developed it had a choice because at the
time there is a competition and so you
could look at that as a deterministic
factor also that once some you know
spark goes off and there's this idea of
the nuclear bomb right the superpowers
have no choice but to develop it and
have no choice but to go into the
nuclear that's one of the arguments for
technological determinism yeah that's
right that certain you can't Fitz yeah
that some technology sort of push you
like this some would say and I would
probably say that we still have control
that we can still make a choice and
getting to that position that we were in
was still a choice I mean now we're
trying for we're attempting to do
nuclear disarmament and that's a choice
to take that away whether that can work
so you can't take away is the knowledge
yeah how to build a box with everyone
disarms then should things get you know
that's again people will start building
it right yeah really can never go back
yeah that's yeah that's that's an
argument for some people theorize you
kind of fact destroyed knowledge but
we ready mr. books enough in a thousand
years yeah well there's a contemporary
examples of countries doing that in
explicit and I suppose a waste it's hard
yeah so I think again another another
sort of telltale sign for this is when
people say talk about technology
evolving that's another sort of use of
language that raises a question for me
because technology itself in my in my
view i don't think actually evolves
humans of change their uses of
technology and technology changes but to
say that technology itself evolves i
think is a problematic thing another
common ways this idea that the
technologies we have are the best that's
a very common idea people think oh the
technologies we have are the best are
they the best we don't know this whole
umbrella technological determinism in
technology evolved in this direction and
the current one is the best I think
people spend a lot of money you know to
make us all believe ft right idea that's
right particularly some technological
tycoons and Seattle and maybe in Silicon
Valley yeah there's a couple of guys I
have in mind or thought it was certainly
in their best interest to make you think
that in order to get best access to the
internet you need this best technology
browser which works with this best
operating system android best platform
it goes in this way and no thankfully we
make it yeah exactly and those ideas I
think seep into the culture and seep
into the discourse and people who don't
engage in technology tend to think that
and they have a sort of resignation that
they don't play an active role in
technology that technology is just there
ok will they buy the product or they're
sort of passive consumers of technology
and not active agents in technology and
I think this idea of technological
determinism helps us remind ourselves
that we are active agents well it may be
a little easier for you guys but it's
important that everyone realize even
those unskilled and untrained are active
agents in shaping what technologies
happen and what technologies
forward a lot of people don't see that
all the time okay so the last case now
in terms of music technology in music in
our look so far at music technologies do
we have examples of does muse our look
at music technology support this idea of
technological determinism or does it
counter it can we think of some things
we've seen so far like I mean could the
development of like a certain temp
instrument well the logical sequence
approach they got it really started like
a loop moving all the way down to
electric guitar a determinist might say
yes the electric guitar is the logical
outcome of the ode a determinist might
say that do you think that's true I
don't know I feel like probably wouldn't
be the case because I mean it's either
looking at it like the development and
evolution of the instrument if I did the
course of music history or it's the
other way around the music history
affected the evolution you want to call
it the history right so like I'd like to
get more veggies me too quite a bit of
music technology follows computing power
which is determined by literally a law
Moore's law so it's not determined by
Moore's law Moore's Law is empirical
based on an estimation of what happens
it's not the term Inge is a law I don't
think it's a law if you're not coming
out with a better shader 18 what's your
breathing oh ah oh is it a blah I don't
think it's a yeah it's a economic
practice so music technical head what
seems to me is
confused they have no way of kind of
measuring how successful theory is right
like I feel like what we need to be
looking at is their predictive power
right so if we have a theory that says
all the technologies are going to
determine what happens next then we
should be able to kind of you know put
these building blocks together from
where we are now and say okay tenure
satellite here is exactly what to it
what's going to be there and then you
know we can measure that right um this
hasn't happened right now these theories
have been around for a long time so I
feel like the ones that claim that
things are determinist or deterministic
they should really be able to back it up
and they have it right so I agree and
that makes it very clear and simple but
I find what I find really interesting is
that these ideas of technological
determinism sort of seep into our
culture and seep into our discourse even
though as you point out there there's
some ways we're very clearly it could be
tested and could be shown to not always
follow in certain many cases they do say
like you mentioned Robert runner in
there and how runner has this thing
working to determine isn't that one of
the reasons that you might think or eat
or not approve or anything is that
people have predicted historically
technological development that's right
which is sort of the crazy idea I think
because it's not like they predicted a
lot of things yeah and so it's sort of
hard like that's right oh wait
Nostradamus is right three out of a
thousand times like people say grams
going to be like flying skateboards
right well there is the issue of sort of
simultaneous discovery where people
separated in different regions come up
with the same inventions at the same
time there's many examples of that which
is kind of an interesting case but again
to music technologies I mean I think
music technologies pose an interesting
challenge to this idea of technological
determinism because one we see the role
of aesthetics and cultural factors
making the choices that determine what
technologies are successful and how they
are used nobody intended the the disc
based player of a gramophone to be used
as a musical instrument for altering the
playback speed nobody intended the
components of a radio to be hacked
together to build a synthesizer nobody
intended countless other examples of
repurposing that was one of our articles
talked about the idea of repurposing
technologies we see many examples of
that in music technology we were talking
about the attraction to 8-bit
technologies we see people going back to
older technologies inferior technologies
for aesthetic reasons not for a
technological logical sequence and I
think those give us some interesting
examples of deviating from the
deterministic approach yeah that's it
absolutely agree and especially you're
saying is that the in order to subscribe
to the deterministic view you
have some sort of predictive power you
know in a new race that you're actually
committing some kind of fallacy that's
really common which is to say because it
did happen in this direction you forget
that there were other possible
directions that I could have gone to
that we're dependent on a bunch of
factors you can think of that you know I
wonder how dependent rock and roll and
all of the technologies go on with it bc
it distortion pedals or different kinds
of guitars and pickups right as
dependent on world war two and you know
the baby boomer generation happening and
the rebellious kids and stuff you mean
just independent of the technology
that's right we never have distortion
pedals right right even it's probably
true right right yeah well the the Scott
model talks about an interconnected web
and I don't like to give agency to
machines that's just my personal opinion
if you guys want to give agency to the
machines in your life no not at all I've
argued very strenuously forth for the
opposite of that and that's a case where
it becomes really really interesting but
this is a really I think a useful thing
for us to think about as we move forward
other comments okay let's make some
noise